aber hast du noch manchmal dieses wenn
du gehen musst das sowas festhalten will
[Musik]
seit einigen tagen läuft wieder
deutschlands vorzeige gesamtschau dsds
im fernsehen und so circa jeder reaction
youtuber hat schon darauf reagiert
meisten leute haben allerdings auf den
homosexuellen kandidaten fabrizio
giordano reagiert und irgendwie sah auch
jedes amt gleich aus hat mich halt übel
krass an diese videos erinnert das war
zufall ich dachte da auf jeden fall her
da haben schon genug leute ihre meinung
zugesagt und da wurden noch gute videos
zu hochgeladen jedoch habe ich dann
heute morgen mal in die trends geschaut
und habe dort dieses video entdeckt
josi meloni mit zeig mir deine melonen
das
wird der hit des jahres seien in der tat
das hier ist also das video auf dass wir
heute reagieren werden
ihr seht schon hier platz 1 in den
trends amon wir sehen doch schon die
likes und discs ich glaube dass liebt
mochte nicht jeder vor wir uns
allerdings die engelsgleiche stimme von
josie meloni meloni kanal wieder
ausgesprochen werde vor wir uns das
anschauen meine lieben freunde schauen
wir erstmal in die kommentare
deutschland sucht den crash so hätten
sie die show tatsächlich von anfang an
lernen müssen bruder muss los sagt man
das noch das doch so 2018 hätte nie
geteilt dass sie mal ein mann war okay
die uci war also früher mal ein mann hat
jetzt beste freundin also angeblich hat
diese dossier parallelen zu meiner
lieblings youtube in katja krasser wird
100 wieder nur fake und bezahlt genauso
wie wir fabrizio traurig habe ich
ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung von ob das
gefängnis oder bezahlt ich glaube
einfach es gibt wirklich so bescheuerte
leute die die aufmerksamkeit suchen ich
habe auch zwei millionen bloß woanders
an der stelle würde ich sagen starten
wir dann auch mit der reaktion
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wirklich melonen ihr müsst euch einfach
mal forsch wenn meine liebe lupu ich
habe gerade bei google eingegeben
deutschland sucht den superstar da
kommen verschiedene sängerinnen und
sänger wollen den titel des neuen
superstars da wir müssen sie mehrere
runden überstehen bei denen die jury
über ihr weiterkommen entscheidet sobald
sie jetzt in die mottoshows schaffen
entscheidet das publikum
da denkt man an eine seriöse gesangsshow
mit vernünftigem publikum in einer
vernünftigen jury
josi
ich habe gehört ist kleiner als t ich
habe ich gedacht dass die perfekte größe
für meine melonen
ist das ppp sitzen da überhaupt alles in
der jury dieter bohlen saviano und
pietro lombardi das kann ja nur gut
werden steht es schwarz haare kein
problem
wie heißt du ich finde die city auf
beide systeme loni das ist mein
künstlername
wie viel make-up hatte eigentlich im
gesicht also die show sie hat dich
wirklich mit nachnamen meloni sondern es
ist die künstlername anscheinend bringt
sie dann zu jedem konzert melonen mit
[Musik]
finde ich krass dass der täter das
direkt so fragt ich meine ist ja nicht
schlimm so jedem das was er möchte und
jeder kann seinen körper ja so verändern
wir das liebt und möchte aber ich würde
jetzt nicht direkt so raus fragen und
ohne scheiß ich jetzt auch nicht vorher
gedacht ich hätte gern also ich würde so
blöde aber ich hätte gern so schulter
wie du ja weniger schultern ja das ist
eine gesangsshow die unterhalten sich
darüber schultermuskulatur können ist
alles schon ein bisschen umändern lassen
ich hatte mit 19 jahren habe ich mir
meine brüste machen lassen gehört
einfach zum schritt dazu dich ohne
werden die einfach nicht groß genau ich
habe die geschlechtern gleich eine
operation mit 21 gemacht also liebe
allein dass die hier im hintergrund
irgendwie so bilder machen ein drittel
des videos ist bisher nur damit voll
dass sie sich vorstellt und sagt dass
sie früher ein mann war
wahnsinn wie hast du noch manchmal
dieses wenn du gehen musst das sowas
festhalten will
der pietro lombardi wurde nur für seine
wichtigen beiträge in die schau geholt
wo hast du noch manchmal dieses wenn du
gehen musst das etwas festhalten will
da brauche ich glaube ich gar nichts
mehr zu sagen das habe ich nie gemacht
sie hatte mit 21 die op dass sie da
unten rum sage ich mal
halles dementsprechend weiblich gemacht
hat als wenn sie bis sie 21 war kein
einziges mal seinen beziehungsweise ihr
glied festgehalten hat beim pinkeln das
ist ziemlich ekelhaft schöne zähne ins
gesicht
lasst sie doch mal singen bevor ihr die
ganze zeit sagt höhe breite schultern
ein schönes gesicht schöne züge aber
dann ohne eigenen song
das ist zeigt mit einem belohnen heißt
es
oh mein gott wo sie ich bin gespannt mit
einem belohnt inhalt saison
das wird hundertprozentig in
einblendungen alles klar machen
wenn du eine riesen stimme hast viel
versprechend aber christoph für die
gefällt meine idee war dann okay also
der song beruht darauf zeig mir deine
melonen weil die jersey meloni immer auf
ihre melonen reduziert wird das immer
gesprächsthema ist also der
hintergedanke ist auf jeden fall
vorhanden und das ganze lied soll in die
sparte ballermann gehören also richtig
scheiße du mich an und ich frag mich nur
an geht er waren dauert nicht mehr lange
bis du komm du bist du auch so jetzt
stehst du
ich vor mir und zu sehen sein wird eine
melone mit 4 1 cockpit und sind wir
haben
los und außer rand und band
drei wochen später
[Musik]
das wirklich
2.0 eine melone
also
das ist wirklich 11 katja einfach nur im
fernsehen anstatt auf youtube aber gut
wir schauen wir weiter
[Musik]
das hier beschreibt dsds
ganz allein dass sie dafür hin auch
gestolpert ist rtl wahnsinn
[Musik]
ich würde es nicht wundern wenn die dose
dir zeigen würde du gehst natürlich sehr
sehr offensiv wie der ganzen geschichte
um du kannst aber wie gehabt dass das
innerhalb jeder übrigens als ich sehen
einfach auf einer emotionalen ebene
menschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend
[Musik]
die josie meloni ist mega sympathisch
andere die da irgendwie ankamen und
dachten sie wären so oder so wie sagt
man wie die last nicht wahnsinnig heiß
das alles ganz locker wahnsinn da war
schauen was er der pietro sagst du hast
du noch manchmal dieses wenn du gehen
musst das etwas festhalten
das war's
mal ganz kurz der xavier naidoo hat eine
sache gesagt der pietro hat nur gefragt
ob sie da unten beim pinkeln manchmal
denkt dass sie was anfassen muss und die
hier diese frau die hat nichts gesagt
okay doch aber sonst hat wirklich die
komplette zeit nur dieter bohlen geredet
eine melone also zwei mal was gesagt
jetzt ist hier nur noch auto
leute die da ist da einfach nur um da
kann ich auch dsds jurymitglied werden
anders hätte würde ich meine reaktion
auf dsds josi meloni jetzt allerdings
auch beenden meine lieben freunde wenn
es euch gefallen hat dann würde ich mich
sehr sehr toll war einen daumen hoch
unter diesem video von euch freuen soll
ich eventuell auch weitere dsds
kandidaten in der zukunft reagieren
vorerst nicht in den nächsten tagen weil
meine gehirnzellen müssen sich halt
erstmal wieder aufbauen aber werde der
bock drauf habe das gerne einen daumen
hoch bei diesem video da schreibt mir
gerne eure meinung zu sie will ohne
unten in die kommentare und jetzt
abonniert main kanal
[Musik]